Let's pray together over day 16, an undivided heart in
Psalm 86:11.
Father, thank you for teaching us your way.
We believe that you're not hiding the way of holiness from us.
We believe that you're not concealing it behind
mystical experiences or undoable things.
We believe that we can rely on your faithfulness.
You are true in the inward parts. You are true all the way to
the core of your holy being.
So Lord, teach us your way.
We know that you're not hiding it, so show it to us.
Give us, Lord, an undivided heart.
Give us insight, Lord, to see where our heart is double-minded
or divided,
where we have not just dirty hands, but an impure heart.
So we pray that you would give us wisdom to see that.
And Lord, we,
like David, are inspired by the Holy Spirit to
pray that you would heal that division in our
heart, that you would not allow us to live out our days
divided and pulled one way and then pulled
another way, pulled God's way and pulled our way.
But instead, Lord, we pray for the Holy Spirit's work
to do that uniting work in our heart
so that our heart would not be broken in the way we
live our lives, but that it would be united.
Please, God, I pray that you would help us to
live in the fear of the Lord because of
this
undivided heart. Lord, so often we've lived
not in the fear of God. We've lived in the fear of man, or we've
lived in selfishness. But instead, Lord, give us a united
heart,
one that is able to really fear your name
and your reputation and to live for the glory of your holiness.
Change our heart so that it leads to a change in behavior, we pray in
Jesus' name.
Let's continue in prayer, seeking God's face and his holiness together.